hola a todos soy sal de khan academy
durante casi toda la historia de la
humanidad desde que éramos
cazadores-recolectores o antiguos
agricultores teníamos mucho tiempo en el
que podíamos simplemente observar cosas
y no estar sobre estimulados sólo había
un riachuelo burbujeante pero ahora
estamos constantemente sobreestimulados
por las redes sociales las cosas que
tenemos que hacer en la escuela lo que
hay que hacer en el trabajo nuestros
teléfonos sonando recibiendo diferentes
mensajes de texto y antes de que podamos
darnos cuenta en la sociedad moderna
nuestros pensamientos están tomando el
control de nosotros y realmente no
tenemos la paz y la quietud que
quisiéramos y es así que algo que
encontré en mi vida es que si todos los
días puedes tomar un momento para dejar
que tu mente se calme y simplemente
observar tus pensamientos esto puede ser
increíblemente poderoso va a mejorar tu
estado de ánimo y en general vas a ser
una persona más feliz
funcional